Fraser price is trying but it's America
who have the bragging rights again
track star and Olympic gold medalist
Tori Bowie has died she was 32 years old
the agency that represented Tori icon
Management Incorporated announced the
news of her death in a tweet writing
that they're devastated over the loss of
a client dear friend daughter and sister
adding quote Tori was a champion a
beacon of light that shined so bright
the track means the word of me has
changed my life it saved me this is
what's always on my heart and my mind
and I feel like whatever's on your heart
and your mind that is what that's what
you're supposed to be doing
Tori was reportedly found dead Tuesday
in her Florida home no cause of death
was given by her management company Team
USA or the Olympics
to lose
it's come up Tory Bowie
10.85 seconds the American is the world
champion
Tori was born in Mississippi and
competed on her college track and field
team in her home state it was there she
became a two-time NCAA champion in a
long jump event
the journey will not be easy not even
close to being easy and
just trust it trust the process whatever
comes along you know
try to try to conquer it and move along
to the next step in 2016 Tori traveled
to Rio as a member of Team USA for the
Summer Olympics she took home three
medals the silver and the 100 meter dash
the bronze and the 200 meter dash and
gold alongside her teammates for the 100
meter relay she could do nothing to
close that Gap and it was Tori Bowie who
had the Glorious glorious honor of
anchoring the Americans to yet another
fabulous gold medal I just want people
to know that we're just able to do
whatever we said our minds to go one day
I hope that I can come to Sandhill and
it's this huge sign that says welcome to
sand here you know home of Tory Bowie
thank you
[Music]